he was an Academy Award winner for glory
and a nominee tonight for his
performance in Malcolm X the other guy
is the man who told us there's no crying
in baseball unless you work for George
Steinbrenner baseball the opening days
next week and George is going to be
throwing out the first manager would you
please welcome two great actors Denzel
Washington and Tom Hanks
when the screen tells us a story based
on the absolute truth it's usually a
documentary film if it's a distortion of
the truth it's usually a news report the
nominees for documentary short subjects
are at the edge of conquest the journey
of chief why why
Jeffrey O Connor producer beyond
imagining Margaret Anderson and the
little review Wendy L Weinberg produces
the colors of my father a portrait of
Sam Borenstein Richard elsens Sally
Buckner producers educating Peter Thomas
C Goodwin Jared Dean würzburg producers
when abortion was illegal untold stories
Dorothy Fadiman producer for the best
achievement in documentary short
subjects the Oscar goes to educating
Peter Thomas C Goodwin and Geraldine
Wordsworth producers
pretty heavy and you have to carry to
thank you Academy and I'm dedicating
this to my partner Tom Goodwin business
partner who died this past year and his
wife Dorothy Jackson at home box office
I want to thank for her vision and faith
Sheila Nevins and thank you michael
Fuchs Cowell Rosen Milton Ginsberg and
carry on tolls thanks and love to
Peter's family Martha Stallings and the
third grade class at Gilbert Linkous
doug biklen gary griffin bob
Silverthorne dan rogers and from
state-of-the-art laura kneeboard Debbie
Merton Roberta Hank and Susan Gonzalez
my family and siblings my husband Grady
my daughter Charlotte and Emily and I'd
like to say for the advocates of full
inclusion for people with disabilities
in our society let us please move
forward thank you very much
and she also wanted to thank Michael
didn't know now let's look at the
nominated documentary features they are
changing our minds the story of dr.
Evelyn hooker
David Hoglund producers fires of Kuwait
Sally Dundas producer liberators
fighting on two fronts in World War two
William miles Nina rosenbloom producers
music for the movies Bernard Herrmann
Margaret's Milo Roma Baron producers the
Panama deception
Barbara Trent David Kasper producers and
the Oscar for best achievement and
documentary features goes to the Panama
deception Bardo trench and David Cutler
pollution
thank you
first I'd like to acknowledge a most
remarkable man the writer the editor one
of the producers the co-founder and
co-director of the empowerment project
which supports many filmmakers every
year
David Kasper as well as the other two
producers without whose perseverance the
film would never have been completed
nico pani guty and joanne doris show
we'd like to take a moment and dedicate
this film to all the people who have
worked so hard for justice and truth and
peace around the world and particularly
the four people who have died who were
working in association with this film
and the hundreds and possibly thousands
of Panamanians who died in this invasion
whose stories might never otherwise be
told because of the deceptive practices
and tactics of our government in with
the complicity I don't like it either
but it's the way it is with the
complicity of the major media we would
like to also dedicate the film to the
courageous Panamanian journalists and
human rights activists who have defied
the Panamanian ban against the screening
of this film at personal risk to show it
in the last few weeks in Panama which by
the way reversed the censorship ban
which was nationwide and to the millions
of Americans who may or may not get to
see this film now that public TV has
also refused a broadcast in in closing I
just like to say we have a tremendous
amount of potential in the world and
those of us here have a perm endless
amount of potential to impact the war
let's use it let's challenge this new
administration to reverse the legacy
that we have left through our policies
in the world and become the Americans
that were capable of thank you very very
much
another record
you know when you're growing up where I
did Long Beach Long Island sitting there
with my brothers and my mom and my dad
watching this show all the years we
watched it you never think you'd get to
say this sentence
ladies and gentlemen Sophia Loren